my channel is sponsored by manscaped
which means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of this video
hello everyone and welcome to another q
a this one is a personal q a if you want
to leave questions for the next q a be
it gaming or personal leave them below i
go through both options to find
questions for the next q a whatever you
want gaming ones are all about gaming
the personal ones are literally
everything else and also um still with
this very
spicy camera and i asked uh ethan whose
house i'm staying at um if he had any
christmas hats for the purposes of
recording this video and for another
video i went to record this week uh
because it is christmas eve happy
christmas eve to all who celebrate and
this is what he had he was like yeah
there's one in the office
and um
this was it
so i moved myself down in the frame just
to make sure we get him in all his glory
okay question time let's go bradley
fiore asked hi alana do you have any
advice for dealing with or avoiding bad
audience members in movies i just saw no
way home really enjoyed it by the way
and very calmly asked somebody next to
me to be quiet just by looking at them
and putting my finger over my mouth and
he stood up cast me out and threatened
to beat me up
wow
it turned out fine and i got a free
ticket to another showing but the
experience was very much ruined for a
movie i was incredibly excited about
apart from this incident loud audiences
have been an increasing problem for me
the past few years and i don't know what
to do about it additionally i'm aware of
some theaters that have extra strict
rules about this kind of thing but they
are not always accessible to me or
others
so
everyone i've ever dated has been like
very sensitive to bad movie-going
audiences
um
[Music]
like they get very agitated by people
talking or texting or literally anything
else in a movie theater everyone i've
dated has been like it's almost not
worth taking them because they get very
upset about bad moviegoers
i can't help you here bradley because i
am not one of those people i have this
uncanny ability to
tune things out so like
something that annoys other people
i won't even hear it other people like
that dog won't stop barking and i'll be
like oh yeah
i guess the dog is barking um i'm an
extremely like
excessively passive person
in that
i just don't get annoyed
the advice that i would give you
like based on my own experience would be
just don't just ignore them man just
don't listen to it you'll be fine but i
recognize that that is
me operating on a different level um
that i know is not necessarily relatable
and it's like a superpower i just am not
a person who gets annoyed
i do have a really bad
auditory sensitivity though if an alarm
is beeping i can't tune that out like a
repetitive beep
or
i have a lot of trouble with tick-tock i
basically can't use tick tock as an app
the main feed
of of the front page of tick tock
jumping between different audio all the
time it's like the over stimulation of
it it's so chaotic that um
i find it extremely aggravating so where
organic noises don't bother me
like
people talking in a movie theater
or dogs barking or even babies crying on
a plane i just won't even hear that
stuff mitchell vernon asked how are you
enjoying the new living space thank you
for asking mitchell it is currently a
lot of boxes
so much unpacking um my bed frame
was supposed to arrive this week and got
delayed another two months another two
months i'm just trying to stop living on
a mattress on the floor i've been
sleeping on a mattress on the floor for
so long
but yeah having more space has been
wonderful so far and the thing that i
have found the weirdest
is that i can see the sky at my new
place
the last two apartments that i've had
were you know studio apartments so just
one room with a bed and a kitchen and
they've been so close to other buildings
that i've never
seen anything but another building
the place i am now
i can see a blue sky without walking
outside i feel like that has done
wonders for my mental health like i've
never even had a place that's had a
balcony before so yeah being able to see
the sky has
been really nice it feels like a very
weird thing for a human to say but i
like it
must hey alana what are the viewer
demographics of your videos i assume
it's mostly male 1 given that you've
been sponsored by keeps and manscaped
i've also been sponsored by two makeup
brands and tampax
however i like talking about this
because it's really really interesting
maybe i've said it on a q a before but i
find these stats really interesting
women
disproportionately
watch my let's plays so when i do those
hour-long gameplay videos
women
especially my resident evil series um it
was the same for the
house of ashes playthrough that i did
women so more women watch those videos
way more men watch the podcasts which is
probably in part because i'm the only
girl on those podcasts but the split is
like massive between those two things
and i'm interested to see when i bring
back red loops orange car which is a
podcast that i do
that is like about internet dating kind
of uh that has just been basically
greenlit by my patreon which i just
started um they also just green like
another podcast i had tears for like
once we hit this amount of people
supporting the patreon i will make this
show and they've had two tiers so far so
we have
red lips orange car is returning and we
are making a show called video game
writing 101 where i will talk to a bunch
of different people from different game
studios who have written on games about
how they write games i'm super excited
about it the third one which we have not
hit the goal for yet is voice acting 101
but in any case i'm bringing back red
lips orange car with entirely female
co-hosts which i'm very excited about
i'm really excited about that group i
think it's gonna be super fun ah i can't
wait it's gonna be great and i'm
interested to see if that skews more
female because there are more women on
it maybe i don't know but in any case um
no keeps and manscaped have sponsored me
but so is tampax instead of two makeup
brands so has one hair straightening
brand uh it's it's pretty across the
board there
this video is brought to you by
manscape.com christmas just came early
with the new performance package from
manscaped your jingle balls well thank
you
these ad reads are very fun to make
okay this is an all-in-one grooming
package that is a great christmas gift
for men starting with the lawnmower 4.0
the london 4.0 is a waterproof cordless
body trimmer that's built with advanced
skin safe technology it has a light in
everything this is the crop preserver a
bowl deodorant and the crop reviver a
ball toner keep you nice and fresh
during the day you know what i'm saying
delicious but genuinely i promise you
when i say that the world will be better
off if you use these products just the
whole world your partner will thank you
new to the collection is the weed
whacker which is a nose and ear hair
trimmer it has 360 degree rotary blades
and the same skin safe technology from
the trimmer so it helps prevent tugging
and tears so if you've been extra good
this year make sure you ask santa for
the performance package bye mansky in
the spirit of the holidays if you buy
today you'll also get two free gifts the
shed travel bag and the manscaped
anti-chafing boxer briefs this is them
in their packaging um i wear these all
the time so go to manscape.com and use
my promo code alana 20 for 20 off plus
free international shipping plus these
two free gifts hermione pion asked hi
alana i've seen you in recent fun house
videos and i was just wondering are you
back do you still work there what's the
deal with that why did you go back to
funhouse an interesting question so when
i left funhouse rooster teeth
um
i believe i still said i would show up
in videos and i meant that when i said
it
so i always intended to continue to
support the team um the reason that i
still occasionally go make fun house
videos i go like once every two or three
weeks
outside of my cinematic studio work
hours to go make content with them for
fun i mean i am getting paid to be clear
but um they're a bunch of reasons it's
because uh i am still friends with a lot
of the people there and still have a lot
of fondness for the team and care about
those people and like
want to make them finish deadly
premonition
but it's also because the time that i
left was like a tough time for a lot of
people there and while rooster teeth is
not a startup and is not a small
business fun house still kind of feels
like one in a lot of ways because it is
a really small group of people who are
just really passionate and really
creative and i left at a time where
things were like i said tough for them
and so i always just like i wish that
i was always gonna leave i was always
going to go write a video game that was
my long-term plan that's what i had been
working towards that's why i went to
work at rooster teeth in the first place
is that i wanted to write a video game
and i went from games media to a company
where they made tv shows and animated
shows and
did skits and did some creative writing
on some of that stuff
it's just the timing of when i had to
leave
for that group of people
felt sucky um so yeah i go i still make
videos of funhouse because it's fun
because i like the people and because i
want to continue to support that brand
it is all entirely positive but i don't
see it as going back i see it as never
fully leaving um because like i said in
in the video where i announced that i
was leaving i was like i will still
appear in videos and my point is that i
meant that i actually also still work
with ign semi-frequently i help them
with a whole lot of their fundraisers
over the last
12 plus months i had done some
livestream stuff for them and i had done
some um
sponsored content a couple of things
with ign as well so both the big
companies that i have left i still work
with
a lot of people that i like at both
companies who i enjoy continuing to work
with so that's why i do it rachel
coleman said what are your thoughts on
the queen elizabeth since she is the
head of state for australia i've been
watching the crowd on netflix and i
would love the perspective of a
modern-day australian it seems like her
role is more celebrated in the uk than
in her other constituencies um so yes
australia is a constitutional monarchy
which means that we are still
technically
uh under the queen
we are part of the commonwealth and
there are definitely brackets of
australians really small ones that care
about the royals uh if you were to ask
my thoughts on queen elizabeth i would
say i literally know nothing about her i
know how she looks
but i would not know any more than her
than i would think anyone in any other
western country
whatsoever i basically have absolutely
no opinion
colin beskin said i always thought it
would be weird to have christmas in
summer so how weird was it to have
christmas in winter after moving to the
u.s um
yeah so i've probably been in the u.s
for like half of my christmases right
now
otherwise i go home to australia i love
christmas summer it's so good i miss it
but it's actually not weird at all to
come to the us and have the winter
christmas
because all of the entertainment media
that we consume is winter christmas so
like all of the
holiday movies are still very christmasy
so you know what the american version
looks like so getting to experience it
was actually really cool this thing that
i've seen on tv for my whole life was
like oh let's actually do that let's
give that a try i'm just staying in la
this christmas i have no plans i will
literally just be
in my new apartment playing video games
watching tv
i don't even have any decorations up
i will be doing absolutely nothing other
than just like having a day off like
kind of a bummer but um
i want to be extra safe with the rising
covert cases right now as well and la
doesn't really feel like christmas so
yeah excited to go to colorado pretty
soon to be somewhere that's a little bit
more wintery as part of the holidays
before we go back to work on the third i
believe victoria thomas said what keeps
you going through busy days
when do you take a break do any of her
projects pwl game awards interviews etc
make you nervous if so how do you
overcome it
um all of my days are busy uh virtually
equally busy um my days are generally
always nine am to midnight is what i
would say my average work day is
and then there are usually like two days
a week that are more 9 a.m to 3 a.m
and i try to have a saturday off every
week where maybe i'll stream but i try
to not do anything on saturdays there
isn't anything that i feel needs to keep
me going because i just really like
working um i'm
definitely a part of this machine so
there's no keep me going to it um
and the second question is when you take
a break the answer is i don't
a lot of people ask how i find time to
fit everything in and i think i realized
recently that a i really feel very
strongly that i do not spend as much
time on social media as a lot of my
peers do or probably people on the
internet do
i don't watch youtube for example while
you are watching this q a i am editing a
video
um i don't watch twitch i don't
spend a lot of time on twitter um i just
don't spend a lot of time doing
things that are not work i suppose so i
feel like when other people take breaks
it's like at the end of the day they sit
down and they like watch
tv or whatever
i just don't do that um i just continue
to work danny my projects make me
nervous
no i will say the video game
accessibility awards which is an annual
award show that i created and um you
know i'm executive producer of because i
created it and then i write and produce
and whatever
is very stressful for me right now
um
we're working on it
but it's really hard and demanding and
i wish i could get more help than i have
but we've locked in a sponsor so the
show is happening
next year um but but that one i find
daunting in a lot of ways just because
it is really difficult and it's so many
moving parts and i feel like i have to
answer all of the questions
and i did try to get some help this year
and i have had help i am i'm working
with a company to help me on it
but even that i kind of realized when
looking at it was like what this has
done is like added to more people who
asked me questions um
it actually kind of made it harder
uh not easier so that one is daunting um
how do i overcome it just keep doing it
just keep doing it the show will come
out and i definitely look forward to it
and i think it's important and this is
the thing that i said about
uh this show in the first place is when
i made it last year it almost got too
hard and i almost gave up and then i was
like you can't
just give up on something because it
gets hard especially not an
accessibility award show just because
it's hard doesn't mean you don't do it
you do it even though it's hard and yeah
it feels just as hard this year
um making an award show is tough but
it's happening and yeah how do i
overcome it is i just keep working on it
um but nothing i do makes me nervous
play watch listen definitely doesn't
make me nervous that one's super easy to
do
interviews never have made me nervous uh
i think i'm very
easy where being conversational is
concerned i don't get nervous very often
either i suppose but
i do find the accessibility awards to be
daunting and that is gonna be it for me
today everyone thank you all for asking
questions like i said leave questions
below for the next one if you would like
to have a wonderful christmas everybody
um to let everyone know i am planning to
do a big old
stream
the day after christmas boxing day as we
aussies would call it to try to raise
money for the homeless
as part of thanks miss
i'm probably gonna try and stream most
of the day um i'm not sure exactly what
time yet i have to figure that out with
the other people i'll be playing with
but was definitely planning to do a big
stream to try to raise as much money as
we possibly can for one final fundraiser
for this year so
that will be on twitch
on the 26th and i hope to see you there
that would be absolutely wonderful um
but otherwise i will see you guys next
time
check the link in the description for
more about manscaped i really like doing
those ads they're very funny
and yeah i'll see you guys next time bye